Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper is about creating stunning cloth
simulations that are rich in yarn-to-yarn
contact.
Normally, this is a challenging problem because
finding and simulating all the possible contacts
between tens of thousands of interlinked pieces
of geometry is a prohibitively long process.
Also, due to the many different kinds of possible
loop configurations, these contacts can take
an awful lot of different shapes, which all
need to be taken into consideration.
Since we are so used to see these garments
moving about in real life, if someone writes
a simulator that is off just by a tiny bit,
we'll immediately spot the difference.
I think it is now easy to see why this is
a highly challenging problem.
This technique optimizes this process by only
computing some of the forces that emerge from
these yarns pulling each other, and only trying
to approximate the rest.
The good news is that this approximation is
carried out with temporal coherence.
This means that these contact models are retained
through time and are only rebuilt when it
is absolutely necessary.
The regions marked with red in these simulations
show the domains that are found to be undergoing
significant deformation, therefore we need
to focus most of our efforts in rebuilding
the simulation model for these regions.
Look at these results, this is unbelievable.
There is so much detail in these simulations.
And all this was done seven years ago.
In research and technology, this is an eternity.
This just blows my mind.
The results are also compared against the
expensive reference technique as well.
And you can see that the differences are minuscule,
but the new, improved technique offers a 4
to 5-time speedup over that.
For my research project, I also run many of
these simulations myself, and many of these
tasks take several all nighters to compute.
If someone would say that each of my all-nighters
would now count as 5, I'd be absolutely delighted.
If you haven't subscribed to the series, please
make sure to do so and please also click the
bell icon to never miss an episode.
We have tons of awesome papers to come in
the next few episodes.
Looking forward to seeing you there!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!